do you do you think that men should have
a say it's like if we're talking about
equality right and if a girl gets
pregnant she wants to have an abortion
that's still the guy's kid do you think
he should have a say in it
like do you think if he says i don't i
don't want her to get one that's my kid
in today's society i would say
no
because the situation is that the woman
is like carrying the child and the woman
um it's quite responsible what happens
to her body so it's going to have a huge
like so you just like you're literally
going to be pushing a child through your
legs if that does if there's a viable um
pregnancy so i feel like a lot of it is
like the woman's part but i do think
that especially with contraception as
well
a lot of like women take the pill and
that's got crazy like crazy side effects
and stuff like that i don't feel like if
she got pregnant i don't feel like it's
the fault of the woman i think the man
had a lot a big decision a big part in
that i do feel like it's like i think if
if you get pregnant it's 100 the girl's
fault i don't think that i feel like the
men get very little responsibility i'm
going to tell you why okay because
interesting because i feel like we have
so many forms of birth control that we
can be on
you can tell him to wear a condom
like don't consent to that i mean like
we're taking out take essay off the
table okay like if that if that happens
to you that is not your fault that's
that's a different different
conversation but if you're like doing it
with a normal guy
like most of them are gonna like listen
to you if if you say no right but take
sesame off the table so i feel like if
you get pregnant it's your own fault as
a girl because we have so many forms of
birth control you can track your cycle
so you know when you're ovulating
you can um you can wear a condom
so
like that all of that is on i feel like
the girls like think about it like why
is all contraception centered around the
woman
i feel like that's another thing that i
feel like
like the woman kind of has to have uh
like if she wants to
get rid of that child like it's also on
the woman she has to go through that
whole thing i feel like there's not much
that the man has to the man has to go
through like the man doesn't have to
take any pills he doesn't have to get
like an implant doesn't have to take any
i think men would if they had it they
just they they just they just have it
that's actually the thing that is a male
um well i think you think drake he went
through the heart like he wouldn't dig
like men don't want like kids running
around either